That is the rub right now with, with black lives matter,
because when you go to the black lives matter, the organizations website,
right? And then I'm not talking about, you know,
the Don Lemon's one uncover for them in the media.
I'm not talking about when you go to the organization's website,
they say things like they're in favor of abolishing, the nuclear family,
I'm censoring LGBTQ plus people, all of this stuff,
all of this stuff that the vast majority of regular
working class, black Americans are not super into or even down with.
So there is a lot of that tension there.
Let's make this about us for a second. So if you take two guys,
like if you take two guys like us, you take Dave Rubin,
you take Rob Smith and you go, wait a minute.
These guys sort of seem like what would be,
I think you could call sort of new conservative, something like that.
We don't look like a, you know, we're, we're both married to dudes.
That's a little different than a, you know, traditional conservatism. Um,
what do you think, what do you think are kind of new role or the younger,
newer conservative role is within the conservative movement?
Okay. So this is what I think. And I've been,
I think about this a lot and it's like everything that I'm doing from, from,
from here on, out with,
with everything that we'll be talking about a little bit is about this.
So it's like,
how do we usher in the conservative movement and the conservative movement into
this new era where you got more black people, you got more,
more people of color, you got more gays, you got whatever.
And I think that what we do is we define a
love for country and a love for America that is not completely uncritical,
but it is not based in some sort of idea that it was
created to permanently and perpetually keep people like us
at, in some way of press. Because I think that the, um, and I was speaking with,
uh, with, with, uh, Lara Trump earlier about this thing.
So this is about creating a more perfect union.
So this is not about pretending that America was always perfect. This is about,
this is about perfecting this union.
And we have to open up this idea of the American experiment to everybody because
what the left says right now, that people like you and people like me and,
and a lot of different people is that America was never for you.
America is not for you. You cannot survive here. You cannot exist here.
This, uh, system is racist.
And the only way that you will ever be free or be successful is if you join
with us in pairing this all down via, via socialism, leftism,
whatever you want to call it. And so our job is to reach out to,
to not only to people like us,
but also these mainstream conservatives that look like your typical
conservative. They, they,
those people make up a lot of the people that follow both of us.
And so in the kind of bring everybody into this of,
of what is America and how do we love America from all vantage points?
Yeah. I think the hard part for some people,
when they see what people like we are doing, people like us,
I think the hard part is they go, well, wait a minute,
there's still such a strong religious bent to the right,
that this just doesn't make sense. They think you guys are sinners,
something like that. And people will go, well, Rubin,
how can you be friends with Shapiro? And it's like, yes,
he has a different view of biblical marriage,
but he's not trying to legislate my life. It does put a cap on our friendship,
right.
I can be friends with you in a way that I can't be with him because of that
thing, but it's, but it doesn't,
but I know he's way more tolerant than all the other people that are screaming
about tolerance all the time. Uh, but what would you say to a young,
a young gay person that is trying to become part of this or,
or understand this? What would you say to them about that?
I would say to them that first of all, just like you articulated it pretty well,
um, is that a difference of opinion and actively legislating against things that
are, are two different things, right. And you know,
it gets into the religious freedom conversation,
which is a whole other conversation as well.
But this is what I say to the younger gay person that is
reaching out to me that may be leaning conservative,
and that has problems with the religious thing. First of all, I tell them,
number one, you know, you're Jewish, I'm Christian.
I think that the left in the far left uses,
um, they use this, this idea that most, uh,
evangelical Christians are super far right? Hate gay people,
all of that stuff to separate them from the gift that is having a connection
to whatever your belief is for me, if that believe in Christianity.
And I believe in God, and they would want to separate these guys,
these young, um,
gays and lesbians from that so that they can worship at the alter of leftism
so that they can worst about the author alter politics so that they can worship
at the alter of, as I always call it the LGBTQ Colt.
So they want these kids worshiping at that altar and not at the alter
of their creator, whoever they believe that they may be,
if that makes any sense at all. And I'll tell you, furthermore,
that I have made inroads with a lot of these
conservative Christians. And they'll say, look, I still believe like you and,
and binge appear, even though you haven't been some parable Jewish,
I'll have these conversations with these conservative Christians and they'll
say, hi, my belief is that marriage is between a man and a woman.
That is what I believe, but you go ahead and live your best life.
And it, neither of us are hurting each other. We can co-exist.
And that is tolerant.
That is tolerance. That, that is America. Uh, you know, it's like, I,
I spoke at Liberty university,
the largest evangelical college in the United States in front of 14,000 kids was
like a true political rally. The biggest crowd I've ever spoken in front of.
And they freaking loved me. And I went around campus all day long,
shaking hands and hugging people. And it was great. And it's like,
those are the intolerant people.
I think we're doing something backwards over here.
Yeah. Maybe. Um, and it seems like nowadays,
like the most intolerant people are on the left.
These are the people that are the most intolerant.
These are the people that are the most likely to, to throw out slurs, you know,
homophobe, racist, not see all of this other stuff.
The people who even slightly, um, disagree with any of their stuff,
or even gen Gentili call out, left as policies.
This is what they do. And these are shutdown terms.
I hope that they start to mean less. Um, as we move into this,
this new world we're trying to get into.
Yeah. So I know you hate sort of the phrase community,
whether we would say the black community or the LGBT community,
because we are all individuals ultimately, but sometimes,
sometimes we just need some of these words to explain situations,
but do you sense a really weird tension in the black community
related to identity because of color and then the sexuality
thing, because it seems to me, and we keep seeing videos of this pop-up online,
where there'll be black people that are suddenly they're stuck in this
intersectional thing and they're suddenly going, no,
I have traditional beliefs and I'm not down with all that LGBT stuff.
And these things have been sort of morphed into a very weird thing where
suddenly, if you, if you're,
you have to be suddenly black trans lives matter,
I'm personally flying with black trans people, of course,
but suddenly they create this thing where it's just like,
you have to be for all of these things,
no matter what your other set of beliefs are.
So that is the rub right now with, with black lives matter,
because when you go to the black lives matter, the organization's website,
right? And then I'm not talking about, you know,
the Don Lemon's one uncovered for them in the media.
I'm not talking about when you go to the organization's website,
they say things like they're in favor of abolishing, the nuclear family, um,
censoring, LGBTQ plus people, all of this stuff,
all of this stuff that the vast majority of regular
working class, black Americans are not super into or even down with.
So there is a lot of that tension there. Um,
and this is the problem with when you let brands,
organizations and corporations define black because
black lives matter does not define black.
My blackness is not defined by black lives matter or any of their founders or
any of the people that have, you know,
put themselves in the position to speak for this organization. Like I said, I,
this is an organization as a corporation. Um,
this is a business and they don't speak for me.
So there is a lot of tension there. And furthermore,
so I talk a lot about, I say LGBTQ cult a lot, right? Um,
so there are gays and they're lesbians and there are bisexuals and there are
transgender people, most of which are law abiding tax,
paying citizens that just want to live their lives and pretty much be left
alone.
Then there is the LGBTQ cult in the cultists
say that you will listen to whatever we say,
whatever we change is the idea.
So if we want to use pronouns,
this is what you call us or else we will find you. Um,
if you do not agree with adding transgender women to the
spaces for actual women,
you are now transphobic and it is all of that stuff that is going
crazy and it stopped. And I break this down.
There's a whole chapter in this book called escaping the LGBTQ cult,
where I kind of break all that stuff down in that is the stuff that
most people are not downward. Most people don't care about.
Gays and lesbians were we're past that point now,
but they see all the cult stuff and they think that that represents all of us.
And it just does it.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlist, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.